Kennedy there is a second good for the  face of ho that I came to the White  House today the message apparently a  member of the vice president's staff  that's - in two days in a building where  people are being tested now including  the president vice president every day  had a temperature check for months here  why should the average American  workplace doesn't have access to these  rapid tests feel comfortable going to  work the White House isn't even safe for  people this individual there is a member  of the vice president's team who is  positive for coronavirus we have put in  place the guidelines that our experts  experts have put forward to keep this  building safe which means contact  tracing  all of the recommended guidelines we  have for businesses that have essential  workers we're now putting in place here  in the White House so as America  reopened safely the White House has  continuing to operate safely